someone told me on stream yesterday i
was like they are completely unrelated
but you said adhd so it came up in my
mind
um i was like no no check because chat
was accusing me of having adhd and i was
like no i don't know what i was like i
can like i can focus on things like yeah
i get really fixated on yeah yeah and
they were like you know focusing too
much is a sign of adhd right and i was
like what yeah
apparently it is yeah how do we so so i
was like wait what so if i if i
concentrate too much on things you have
adhd but if i don't concentrate
i'm
enough
i
have
the hold up what is it what does that
mean what is it how does that work it's
just i don't know it's like you can't be
on too far off the either side of the
spectrum yeah yeah because then you have
a problem because it doesn't specify
that you can't pay attention it's
attention
up with these these definitions that's
crazy it's usually it's usually the
person that says you have adhd
like a fish how do you test if someone
concentrates too much how do you tell i
i'm genuinely curious
it's basically like you can't control
yourself and you realize that oh [ __ ]
it's like oh you're getting interested
in something yeah so you get obsessed
with this kind of repeat that yeah it is
but at the same time it's like you can't
control it but i feel there's a lot of
people like in just this internet age
that you know because we're so
[ __ ] over sensitized and just
overwhelmed with all this [ __ ]
information right all at the same time
right there are so many people who are
just like oh there's so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] to do on the internet do i have
adhd i'm like no you're just on the
internet yeah i wonder i'm like i don't
think like i have a problem i think
there's just so much [ __ ] that's being
shoved in my face yeah that's what it is
sometimes but that's why like i reckon
there's probably i mean like
you have adhd how does it feel i mean i
got it is weird right because the the
reason
i i only like recently got diagnosed
with adhd and it was just like the most
aha moment of my life like of course i
do you know
it's like oh that's what that was
because
like you know especially like growing up
in
asian culture mental health and mental
conditions are very like
don't exist it's like literally that
meme image of just don't be sad like
yeah yeah yeah
cutting the water yeah
in the water don't be sad don't be sad
so i i remember like because i have this
like such as vivid memory in school
right of uh i knew someone in school who
got diagnosed with adhd and they got
like some
like advantage or something and then in
like a test that we were taking right i
got like extra time or something and i
remember like describing like what he
what his experience of adhd was and i
was just like what a [ __ ] liar i he
he like what a [ __ ] liar i do that
and he's getting some free time on an
exam what the [ __ ] and it just like it
was like it just didn't it just for some
reason it just never [ __ ] occurred to
me that uh unfortunately i had the same
symptoms because i was raised not not
even raised but like a lot of people in
my culture and the environment
i grew up with um it was just we it was
put in our minds that you know mental
health just wasn't really like it was
either like a very very serious thing or
just like was just didn't exist and you
just got to get on with it there's no
such thing as a mild symptom yeah yeah
yeah like you either had it or you don't
yeah so what made you think oh i should
go and see if i have it like what was
the turning point well like this can be
awful um
enough comments on trash taste no way
i am actually wait why did you like
fidgeting with things huh because you
were fidgeting with things honestly
seeing myself on camera i'm just like
damn man i do that [ __ ] what yeah like
because like obviously i've never been
on camera and especially with with me
being on camera documented so much on
trash taste i'm like damn i do a lot of
people weird analyze yeah yeah yeah
like i understand you start to notice
habits right yeah yeah yeah yeah i i
start to notice habits because you're
looking at yourself through the third
person
um and then also you know there's
there's always going to be comments that
are like psychoanalyzing and over
analyzing oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll say some
really wild shoes yeah yeah yeah but
then like what i i saw some comments
that are just like [ __ ] they kind of
make sense and then they google it uh
google what they say i'm like damn that
doesn't look like it's uh that doesn't
look like it's just someone talking out
their ass and then like the final straw
was uh meeting someone here who has adhd
and they describe their symptoms i'm
like [ __ ] okay i need i need to go get
diagnosed right i need to go get checked
out um and yeah it was
thanks to trash taste i guess and thanks
to random youtube comments hold on guys
well done guys you uh you're like it's
like the one time in the world where you
guys were actually correct with your
diagnosis
you weren't just a bunch of like reddit
armchair
psychologists and wild ones yeah yeah
this is some wild diagnosis yeah i do i
i i have as well
that's not an excuse to psychoanalyze
all of us okay
a broken clock is right two times you
know guys
i remember my uh my
[ __ ] uh when i was growing up they
everyone was like convinced i had like
dyslexia yeah
and like i was like no i don't think i
do
because i don't really have a problem
reading the words i just really [ __ ]
hate doing it right
but because they would describe the
symptoms to me as like a
uh you know when i was like 10 or
something mm-hmm so so just give some
back story to this uh i you know i went
to a while school i didn't like reading
i like gaming i was yeah probably
from both my parents probably wish that
nobody'd ever introduced me to gaming
yeah but i i i was introduced to gaming
very very young right yeah talking like
four five six i found out about video
games yeah i became like obsessed and i
read the games i i mean i i've said this
before i beat all of like one of the
first games ever played with pokemon
gold in french and i beat the whole game
in french i don't know how even though
you don't know any french yeah this must
have been literally the birth of me
bashing my head against the wall to
figure out yeah video games
not reading so i've been doing this
since like young age not i i never
really like read stuff i just kind of
did it this is probably like it sounds
very like monkey-esque already and not
you know not very it's very like a like
a prime evil like yeah it is very very
it is so and i went to a welsh school so
i didn't really um
read english like ever
we learned everything in welsh i spoke
in welsh in school so i never read
english like ever the only thing i'd
ever read is like we go to the store i
can i can read i just read the [ __ ]
yeah whatever like but like like when i
would be quizzed on like how to spell
[ __ ] i wouldn't know
they'd be like spell said i'd be like oh
yeah i just said zd in it said
yeah
so like so like this is from my age like
whatever like i was [ __ ] awful yeah
so when we started learning english more
i was like yeah i just don't don't read
books ever yeah and they're like what he
didn't read books
my parents were like yeah we tried to we
tried to rick him really but he keeps
playing those goddamn video games
as much pro my parents tried their
goddamn hardest to get me to read it was
just not gonna happen like i was just i
had absolutely zero interest in it yeah
so i was so so bad at english
but like they knew i was very competent
in all other subjects like i was i was
very like you know maths and science and
all that really really high marks like i
was you know i mean i got like like a
star and [ __ ] and maths and all that so
the highest grade you can get when did
engineering all that so there's no
problem with like i wasn't like like bad
at learning yeah it was just i just
hated this one subject right they were
convinced they were like what well if
he's competent in other stuff he just
might have some dyslexia or something i
and they would tell me what the symptoms
were yeah and it was so annoying because
as a kid
this is where i started learning where
adults like [ __ ] with you as a kid yeah
they would like try and spoon feed me
the answers to like say to like dyslexia
right they would like
that i didn't have until i get you to
agree to it just because they wanted to
have like that like so they can tick it
off it's like oh we figured it out yeah
we sorted them out and then whenever i
have any issues they'll be like god
don't worry we'd have to put him work
he's just dyslexic
yeah this is where you like i get it
because the teachers they want an answer
they want to read they want a solution
right they want to know why and i i can
understand everyone wants a reason why
but like
unfortunately mental health and [ __ ]
like that and then and learning is like
the most complicated [ __ ] known to men
and there is never ever just a one
solution that fits all yeah like just
because somebody sucks about something
it doesn't mean there's
an inherent problem so i would like talk
to my teachers and stuff yeah and i
remember talking to my english teacher
and she like made me like stay after
class and she talked to me and she'd be
like so you can read these words right
and i was like yeah i can read them and
she's like they don't look like messed
up or jumbled at all and i was like
i was like no
not really and then she was like
sometimes the words are hard to read i'm
like yeah i don't know the words
sometimes i don't really know it so it's
kind of hard to read because english is
kind of funny and the pronunciation is
weird and then so
she was like okay okay so then another
teacher came in a few weeks later and
started asking me more questions about
dyslexia and stuff and i was like no no
i i the words are not [ __ ] jumbled
okay
i've seen the movies they don't [ __ ]
do that i know that's not how it works
but i'm like yeah i
i do not have a problem i can see all
the letters in order they do not move i
know what i'm reading i am just [ __ ] at
this subject and i don't like it just
like start shaking your body like what
about now yeah yeah
it was literally like i had
i'm thank god i wasn't like uh i wasn't
a kid they were just like and i feel bad
because like kids are so easily like
pushed into saying yes or no yeah i'm so
glad i was a stubborn [ __ ] from like a
young age where i was like no the words
are not jumbled i don't have a problem
reading the words i just hate this
shitty subject i hate english yeah and
they're like no no no no you you have to
be you have to be you have never
you've done as far as you you must be
you you must be i i'm i'm very glad that
i read i don't know where i got the
stubbornness from yeah i was glad
because i i remember like it was really
annoying and i kept insisting i had it
yeah no
no
i do not have this i have no problem
reading of mice and men i just don't
like it i'd rather watch the movie well
i try to just like brainwash you yeah
okay this is what i'm realizing
and i understand now why like you know
this whole discussion about diagnosing
kids is like i get why it's like a
touchy subject and yeah some parents are
like
my kids you can't diagnose them and then
you know some people are so quick to
jump to it it's a really uncomfortable
subject and kind of touchy because yeah
the kids often can't like i was a kid i
couldn't fully express that you know i
can't just be like listen i didn't
really connect with the subject i don't
like it
for themselves right yeah i can't really
fully explain why i don't want to well i
don't engage with this yeah but they you
know they're just like well they're like
no we're the adults we know more than
you yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's kind of a
it's weird man and i think that's why
like
when you get parents that are super
passionate about it and stuff and
there's also the thing of like
some parents
don't want to
get their kids diagnosed with things
because they don't want to like be like
my kid has a problem or has something
right my parents didn't really give a
[ __ ] they were like if he's got it he's
got it whatever you just deal with it
but yeah yeah because i i think with how
mental health is now it's just like it
feels like at least it feels like if
you're diagnosed with something then
then the kind of feeling is oh there's
something wrong with me or yeah yeah
there's something there's something
broken with me because like uh like with
me and adhd for example like i i didn't
realize that i was
abnormal you know because i would have i
would i would do all these things to
basically basically be able to like seem
like i was able to function you know and
i'd i'd only learned recently that that
was like my coping mechanisms for like
my
what it would like my how my brain works
you know yeah i'd figured out ways to
live with it um and i thought everyone
had to do that you know that's that's
just what i thought and like especially
like after being diagnosed it hasn't
like changed my life or anything like
that it's like the biggest thing that
it's done for me is like it's just
helped me understand myself and i think
that's just i think that's like the most
valuable thing yeah right definitely if
you're like making sense of things that
you were like why why am i like yeah
yeah yeah exactly because it's just
helped me like deal with it even more
because i i i just remembered because it
wasn't it wasn't just the youtube
comments as well i remember specifically
seeing this one youtube video and that
was that was like the last rule where i
was like where am i diagnosed
no no where it was like where it was
like what adhd feels like and someone
like someone like edited a video of
their day and like edit it in a way to
like
to like show how they perceive the world
how they perceive the world and it was
like such a one for one
copy of how i see the world i was just
like oh my god so like that was like the
aha moment because i think i think there
was one one scene in particular because
uh he was going about his day and uh he
was like being scolded uh by his teacher
or his mom or something and uh he was
like fidgeting right he was fidgeting
and
uh
and he would get tore off with that
for him because his mum or his teacher i
can't remember who was exactly but he
was just they were just like can you
concentrate please i'm trying to tell
you something serious yeah you're doing
something else and i'm just like and he
said oh but it helps me to concentrate
and i'm just like that's been my entire
life that's been if like i need to
fidget with something in order to
concentrate and if i don't i just lose
like my trail of thought or something
right he's just like me yeah yeah i was
just like
holy [ __ ] maybe maybe i should [ __ ]
go in and get this
how do they
because i've always been curious like
when you go see a doctor right and you
want to like you know figure out if you
are actually diagnosed with it how does
the doctor like
check that
well is it like a test he just puts like
a ruby's cube on the table he's like
i'll be back in 15 minutes it puts like
a fidget spinner on the table what do
you think about it yeah
yeah because i've always been curious
like you know how how does the doctor
like kind of determine whether you
actually have adhd or if it's just like
something similar to that that's not
necessarily adhd right yeah i mean uh at
the moment i'm at like i'm still like
processing it and learning through it
because at the moment at the beginning
they uh take you when they do like this
uh
this just uh it's it's it's a survey at
first so it's like it's like the first
test um and then afterwards if you tick
enough boxes to be like okay there's
there's you know this
there's a chance then you go into the
psychologist and you know they ask you
like a bunch of questions for me at
least i don't know because like uh
another friend in england just recently
got diagnosed with adhd as well and i
think in england they have a different
kind of process it's probably different
yeah yeah i think it's different to
every country uh in england i believe
that's like you have to go to like a
group session as well or something like
that
it's different in every country but for
me it was more just a one-on-one talk
with
uh with my you know with the
psychology psychologist where they just
asked me like very detailed questions
about my experiences how i perceive
events and like i can't remember
everything because there was like a lot
of [ __ ] questions yeah it was kind of
it was basically like a therapy session
where she's like so so tell me about
this
talking about this don't tell me about
that um
and yeah i mean uh
ever since
being diagnosed i've like like i said my
life hasn't changed that much i just
know now it's like written in paper
that's uh that this is the you got the
plaque
no i i i got the plaque of just like
here's
how your brain works and here's why you
your brain does this [ __ ] yeah and like
ever since knowing that i'm like ah that
makes sense now i have like a word to
put to how i've felt for a lot of my
life